We're asked to identify which
expression is larger.
5 squared plus 3 to the fifth.
Or 3 to the fifth and then
that whole thing squared.
So let's just work this out.
So let's do the first
one here, 5 squared
plus 3 to the fifth.
So what is 5 squared?
5 squared is the same
thing as 5 times 5,
which is equal to 25.
So that right there is 25.
And what's 3 to the fifth?
Well, 3 to the fifth is equal
to 3 times 3 times 3
times 3 times 3.
And what's this going to be?
3 times 3 is 9.
9 times 3 is 27.
27 times 3 is 81.
And 81 times 3 is 243.
So this up here is the same
thing as 25, that's what 5
squared is, plus 243.
Which is equal to, we can do
this in our head, 268.
So that's what the first
expression is.
Now let's see what 3 to
the fifth squared is.
Well we already figured out what
3 to the fifth is, 3 to
the fifth is 3 times 3 times
3 times 3 times 3.
It's 243.
So this expression right
here is 243.
And we're going to square
that entire thing.
So this is equal
to 243 squared.
Now, they just want to know
which expression is larger.
And we already have a
pretty good sense.
The first expression
is only 268.
The second expression, the
number is a little bit smaller
than 268, but it's that
number squared.
This is 243 times 243.
Which you might already sense
is going to be a much larger
number than 268.
So you should at this point
already say, hey this is a
much larger number than that.
We don't know the exact
number yet.
But if they just want to know
which expression is larger,
it's definitely going
to be this one.
And if just out of curiosity
you want to know what that
number is, we can solve it.
So if we do 243 times 243.
3 times 3 is 9.
3 times 4 is 12.
3 times 2 is 6.
Plus 1 is 7.
Put a zero down here.
4 times 3 is 12.
Let me do this in a
different color so
we don't get confused.
4 times 4 is 16.
Plus 1 is 17.
Put a 1 here.
4 times 2 is 8.
Plus 1 is 9.
Now let's do this last
row over here.
We have the 2's.
Put two 0's here.
2 times 3 is 6.
2 times 4 is 8.
2 times 2 is 4.
So let's add everything
up and what do we get?
We get just a 9 there,
2 plus 2 is 4.
7 plus 7 is 14, plus 6 is 20.
2 plus 9 is 11, plus 8 is 19.
1 plus 4 is 5.
So you get 59,049 which is
clearly way bigger than 268.